the movie opens during the second world
war where the US B24 liberators are
flying over the Pacific Ocean the
soldiers led by bombarder Lou zerini are
on route to execute a bombing Mission
Against the Japanese controlled aisle of
nauru as they approach their target Lou
commands the air strike and his Crews
follow the order successfully releasing
the bombs not long after the aircraft
faces an onslaught from multiple
Japanese fighter planes resulting in
damage to their planes pilot Phil
informs Louie that their base is 5 hours
away and their brakes are no longer
functional although their craft is shot
at hundreds of times the soldiers
managed to make it back to their base
they attempt to land but it proves to be
almost impossible due to the faults in
the aircraft the tires on the landing
gear come out and start screeching on
the floor despite this setback Phil
manages to bring the aircraft to a stop
at the very end of the runway the scene
then cuts to a flashback showing a young
Italian American Louie living in
Torrance California he appears to be a
brat who always causes trouble and is
chased by the police at such a young age
he smokes drinks liquor and is even
involved in stealing Louis being an
Italian Refugee is often picked on by
other American children his age he also
gets into frequent brawls with them
forcing the police to intervene one day
Louie sits under the bleachers watching
his older brother's baseball game and
drinking his liquor shortly after he is
caught by a guard so he runs away to
avoid any trouble his older brother Pete
happens to witness him running at a
great speed which makes him realize his
potential to become a runner it's
amazing what drinking and smoking will
do for you athletically as a result Pete
decides to train him and encourages him
for the same Louis is a bit hesitant at
first but he agrees after some
insistence as the years pass by he
excels his running skills and wins each
and every race competition he
participates in this ears him the
nickname the Torrance tornado tornadoes
can't run at one point in time he
manages to complete a 1em race in 4
minutes setting a new American record
for high school students with this
accomplishment Louie receives an
invitation to represent America at the
1936 summer olympics in Berlin before
departing for it he shares an emotional
Embrace with his brother and thanks him
for everything Pete imparts a valuable
Insight stating that one moment of pain
is worth a lifetime of Glory Louie will
clearly remember this until the end of
the movie thanks Uncle Ben the scene
then cuts to the day of the Olympics
where Louie participates in a 5,000
meter race as the race commences his
family sits beside their radios to hear
him compete in the first few laps Lou is
left behind by the other formidable
contestants making the situation intense
but eventually he puts all his efforts
and Sprints at full speed overtaking
several Runners despite finishing the
race in eighth position he sets a new
world record by finishing the final lap
in just 56 seconds and another one for
being so lazy in the first he still aims
to win the medal in the next Olympics
which will be held in 19 1940 in Tokyo
however his dream gets shattered due to
the outbreak of the second World War War
back in the present Louie finds Phil
praying to God after successfully
Landing the aircraft he doesn't seem to
have any faith in God so he doesn't care
very much about the prayers starting
from the very next day he continues his
training by running alongside a Jeep he
also impresses his fellow armymen by
beating his own record in the 4minute
mile one day Louie and his son receive
another mission to search for a lost
aircraft and rescue survivors they are
given the same old plane after repairing
it using spare parts despite this the
team including some new members sets off
for their mission the instability of the
plane becomes apparent when one of the
engines fails mid-flight as they try to
make the best out of the situation
another engine fails which causes the
craft to crash in the ocean as a
consequence eight of the crew members
lose their lives leaving only three
survivors Louie Phil and Mac the three
of them get onto the inflatable rafts
and take some time to calm themselves
Mac is completely hopeless and believes
that their chances of survival are zero
but the other two ask him to stay
positive they have limited rft iions
some chocolates and a bottle of water
Louis then decides that they'll eat one
piece of chocolate in the morning and
one at night and drink only two sips of
water a day as night falls they fall
asleep on the boat fighting against the
freezing temperature the following
morning the trio is awakened by the
sound of an approaching airplane in a
quick action they attempt to Signal it
using dye and a flare gun but their
efforts go unnoticed soon after Louie
discovers that all the chocolate boxes
are empty with Mac having consumed them
all freaking MacDonald more like this
infuriates Louie as now they are left
with nothing however he controls his
anger as there's no point in fighting
the three then grapple with survival in
the seemingly Endless Ocean enduring
days without food or water in the midst
of their struggle a seagull lands on
their boat starved the soldiers
immediately grab and devour its flesh to
fulfill their hunger however their
stomachs can't hold on to it causing
them to vomit after this they come up
with the next plan they use the same
seagull's flesh as bait to catch fish
they then take turns to have a bite of
the fish bringing them temporary
satisfaction as time goes on their
situation grows increasingly dire
moreover they are battered by a sea
storm one night which makes them feel
that their lives are slipping away from
their hands at this critical moment
Louie turns to prayer saying that he'll
serve his whole life for God if he saves
them now miraculously they survive the
storm and the following morning brings
rain the crew happily fills up their
containers and drinks the drops from the
sky in the next few days they
successfully managed to catch a shark
provided them with much needed
sustenance on the 27th day of drift the
crew spots another plane in the sky they
shoot their flare gun to attract
attention and the plane turns around
giving them a new sense of hope however
their happiness is shortlived because it
turns out to be a Japanese aircraft that
begins shooting at them in a desperate
bid to save themselves the crew jumps
into the water dodging bullets and also
fending off sharks shortly after the
aircraft flies away after which the
trios swim back up despite evading the
danger their inflatable boats are damage
to do to the bullets they hurriedly
patch up the holes so that they can
remain afloat and save themselves from
shark attacks time continues to pass and
the three of them spend their days and
nights on the same small boat it has
been over 40 days since they became
stranded in the ocean Max condition
deteriorates to the worst and as a
result he slowly succumbs to hunger
Louie and Phil wrap up his body and drop
it in the water surprised they didn't
eat him honestly following this the
remaining two continue clinging to life
but their condition has deteriorated to
the point where they are unable to talk
or stand on the 47th day of their ordeal
they come across a ship that
unfortunately belongs to the Japanese
soldiers resulting in their immediate
capture now prisoners of War Lou and
Phil are confined in separate Dark Cells
on quadulan at there they're provided
with a meager sustenance of rice balls
which they hungrily consume one day the
two American Airmen face interrogation
by a Japanese Colonel who seeks
information about newer bombers and the
nordan bomb site having extracted some
details from from them Louis and Phil
are transported to another prison camp
in Tokyo alongside other prisoners upon
arrival they're separated in the vast
crowd and are sent to different P camps
Louie finds himself at amori Detention
Center under the supervision of a
cruel-hearted commanding officer
Corporal mutsuhiro wanabi according to
wanabi all the prisoners are the enemies
of Japan so they'll be treated
accordingly while explaining prison
rules wanabi spots Louie looking him in
the eye so he beats him up with a thick
wooden stick after making them stand for
a whole day the new prisoners are sent
to their Camp Hut where Louis meets
other American soldiers the next day the
prisoners are assembled on the ground
and watan ABI identifies individuals
with particular talents noticing Lou's
athletic background wanabi initiates a
race between Louie and a Japanese
officer clearly exhausted from lack of
food Louie collapses to the ground which
causes him to receive further beatings
it's apparent that Watson Obi hates him
the most as he subjects him to more
frequent physical and brut brutal
assaults apart from enduring hard labor
in the camp the American soldiers also
managed to stay informed about the war's
progress via newspapers pilfered from
the Japanese a marine Soldier keeps
track of American positions but he's
soon caught by the Japanese soldiers as
a consequence he is beaten up
mercilessly while Louie and the other
prisoners watch on helplessly a few days
later Lou is given an opportunity to
send a message home confirming his
survival turns out that the US
government has already classified him as
killed in action agreeing to he's taken
to a radio station where he delivers a
message to his family he's also forced
to falsely claim that he's being treated
fairly so that they can get some mercy
from the American government in the war
after this Louis is offered good food
after a long time however this gesture
comes at a price as he is later asked to
broadcast another message containing
anti-American propaganda the Japanese
men also offer him a great life in Japan
if he does it but the latter refuses to
betray his principles and is
consequently returned to the p camp once
back wanabi tells Louie that he's strong
like himself and that they'd have been
friends if they weren't enemies but
since Louie refused to comply with the
Japanese order wanabi has all the
prisoners punch him in the face one by
one this punching spree lasts for an
entire day leaving his face bruised and
battered one day the prisoners are
instructed to perform a play of
Cinderella to amuse the Japanese
soldiers amidst this watan ABI sits next
to Louie and tells him he has been
promoted to Sergeant so he'll be leaving
amori the next day he asks Louie to
congratulate him on the promotion but
the latter remains silent the life of
the prisoners at the camp gets immensely
better after his departure however the
good days don't last long as the Allies
bomb the neighboring City causing the
prisoners to be relocated to another
Camp called now at Su upon arriving
there Louie momentarily passes out at
the site of Wabi who is unfortunately
the commander of this Camp wanabi
delivers the same speech and hits Louie
for no reason starting from the very
next day the labor work continues and
the prisoners are assigned to load large
bags of coal onto the ship which is even
more exhausting than before the weight
of the bags and their fatigue combined
causes some men to fall over the railing
and die one day Louie who is extremely
exhausted pauses doing work so he is
brought to Watson ABI who then punishes
him by making him lift a large wooden
beam and hold it over his head Louis
struggles but Watson ABI orders a guard
to shoot him if he drops it as a result
Lou holds it up for several hours
despite the physical strength every
prisoner has their attention on Louie
and they cheer for him in their low
voices wanabi expects him to drop the
beam but Lou lifts it even higher while
fearlessly staring at the Sergeant's
eyes unsettled by his Defiance wanabi
beats him brutally and abandons him in
the same spot for the entire night the
next day a superior Japanese officer
announces the ceasefire and instructs
the PS to go take a bath in the nearby
River the prisoners initially believe
that they're going to be executed but as
they get into the water an American
bomber plane flies overhead indicating
that the war is finally over all the
prisoners celebrate their Victory and
soon after the supplies are dropped in
the camp amidst the celebration Louie
tries to find Waton ABI in his quarters
but he seems to have already fled he
then sits down and stares at a picture
of wanabi as a child alongside his
father in the aftermath Louie and the
other PS return to their home country
where their families are waiting for
them at the airport at the end of the
film a slideshow depicts the real Lou
post-war life he married and had two
children Phil to survived and married
wanabi went into hiding and evaded
prosecution after being listed on the
top 40 Most Wanted Japanese war
criminals Louie lived out his promise
and devoted his life to God with this
newfound Faith he decided to forgive his
wartime captors by meeting with many of
them but Waton ABI still refused to meet
him though Louie couldn't win the medal
he fulfilled his dream of running in the
Olympics at the age of 80 subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching